So far, we have designed an abstract coffee maker with three classes and
a set of behaviors. By abstract I mean we, we haven't done anything specific to
the Mark IV. This design is of value by itself. That is,
it could be used in a variety of different models. And so
we want to somehow, be able to capture that and reuse it later.
Hence we should not add specifics to it, instead we should sub class it for
each specific coffee maker. By sub class I mean have a sub class for
each of the classes that is part of the overall system.
In particular, the dependency inversion principle says that high level modules,
like the ones that we have just designed, should not depend on low level ones.
Like those wrapping the API.
Note that this is the opposite philosophy from layered architectures,
where high level model, modules are built on top of low-level ones.